A few weeks back I mentioned breaking out in a rash. I've said several places. It's still there around my shoulders, lower back, spine left, right thigh and under right knee, and sometimes along both caps, itchy at different times.
Is this a detox reaction or is, can this be related to liver having too much to filter, et cetera?
At what point is it a concern? When I first mentioned this, I recently changed lower detergent as the older was discontinued now I switched to an organic related detergent.
So can a person have hives and rash because they're overwhelming their liver and you're trying to detox through the skin? Yes.
Another thing that can stimulate hives and rash is a huge emotional change, stress change, stress under your adrenals. I remember when I was in school after my finals of my first semester, it was so stressful. I literally broke out in a rash all over my body for two weeks.
It was the two week break from you don't wear because I didn't get any rest for two weeks. I was just under so much stress that can do it. So can I have allergy reaction all of a sudden from something that can do it.
Usually, if it's from a detergent, like I initially said, usually that would go away after a period of time. Here's what I would suggest to try to figure this out.
Number one, I would do a CBC. That's a complete blood count, which you're really looking for is an increase in eocinophils.
To see if it's an allergic reaction of something like an allergen to something. If there's a spike in eocinophils, then that's what we really know what's going on. It can be an allergy to some environmental.
Typically, once you're going to see an eocinophil reaction, if your CBC is all completely normal, there's nothing abnormal there, then we just got to keep digging, is there a food sensitivity, then you have to look at that possibility.
Like, well, I've never had food sensitivities before and I'm not eating anything different in my diet. Well, you can develop antibodies to different foods for a zillion different reason.
And if the only way to really know that is to do a Syrex array and test to see if something is going on with that.
The most common foods would be your basic, most common foods would be gluten dairy eggs, corn.
So you could do a food elimination to see if it's something like that that's going on.
If it's like liver is overwhelmed, you'd have to go, well, again, why would your liver be overwhelmed unless you're exposed to a whole lot of toxins?
I've had people throughout my years have a reaction like this because they were farmers and they just put GMO corn on their field or they just sprayed their field with pesticides.
And they weren't very, very careful, but they're exposed to a lot of chemicals.
And I've had people that were painters and they did a big painting job where they did a spray job and they're exposed to a different chemical in a paint like this.
I have one person that their child had broken out like this and we couldn't figure out what it was and actually went over to their house and tested it.
And the children's bedroom, they had just moved into a brand new long cabinet they had painted with linseed oil on the inside of the cabinet.
And then the, the mother did some research on linseed oil and found that all linseed oil except if you get a natural organic linseed oil, which was like four times as expensive linseed oil needs to be rendered so it's rendered they add arsenic to the rendering because it speeds up the rendering process and they can sell it a lot cheaper.
So the one bedroom wall where the four kids or the three kids were in bunk beds in that bedroom was still sticky it just didn't dry correctly and the kids were exposed to the arsenic and the linseed oil.
So I would I would kind of search for maybe you have already done that I would search for environmental factors that maybe something you're exposed to or that if you could put your figure on.
Just to say oh it's a detox reaction and then a big fan of you know just blaming the detox reaction now if let's say you were eating horribly your whole life and then you just made a major change.
And you're dieted you're starting to clean up your diet you could have a reaction that could last a few days to a week or maybe even two weeks, but this isn't the case with the person who wrote this so I would I think we need to dig a little bit deeper and see what's going on because I would have thought that this would have cleared up by now so if you need some help we can chat about that.